um i know there's only about
10 or so minutes left so i'll try to
keep it quick you have about 20 minutes
we'll probably run
10 minutes over it's okay go ahead okay
sounds good and uh i mean
um also a lot of this work is an overlap
of
mark mark's work and a lot of this is
uh so there's parts that we can we can
definitely
gloss over here so um this work is done
in collaboration with um laura graves
and
the nancy ashok and under the
supervision of pj ganesh
[Music]
deep neural networks have been
successfully applied
and many many fields we've had
quite a few talks here about them
already
especially this has led them to be used
in safety critical settings
such as controlling autonomous vehicles
as a consequence there is a need for
these testing analysis and verification
tools that are
um tuned or specialized for uh these dns
um so we wanted to start off with this
general definition a
problem that all of these dnn tav tools
are designed to solve
and we call this the dn and sat problem
so the dna side problem
goes as follows given a dnn model m
a label y and constraints fee which are
over the inputs
the parameters and the outputs of the
model determine whether there exists an
input x to m
such that m labels x as y
and fee holds true
uh while this is simple you can uh
imagine that we can
encode many types of constraints here
and in the next slide i'll
give an example um so a couple things
one these constraints are designed in
such a way that
satisfying the constraint leads to
property violations
and two we don't necessarily need to
look at this as a decision problem
it can be thought of as an optimization
problem especially in settings where
constraints fee may never be completely
satisfied
so um an instantiation of it concrete
example
is adversarial robustness and
mark gave a um definition of it earlier
so i'm going to
keep it a little quick here but
essentially adversarial robustness
is the absence of um adversarial
examples
and here i'm using the definition by
zico coulter and
alexander madre for addressable
robustness there can be
different ways you can define
adversarial examples but we're using one
of them here
so in order to formulate this
dnn sat problem for adversarial
robustness we would
include an input x and make an assertion
or check whether the m the model
m labels x's y and in addition
we determine whether there is an
additional input
z such that the model m does not label z
sy
and the distance between x and z is less
than some threshold delta
now this distance function can be
dependent on the the type of
uh domain so for example in the case of
vision
we often use l infinity distance um or
l2 distance
or in the case of natural language you
would use something like cosine distance
or edit distance
so now that we've defined the problem
that the dna and sat
tab methods or the dntav methods are
aimed to solve let's look at some
properties that an ideal
tiv method would have for one it should
scale well
it should scale to industrial size dns
industrial size dnns
like gpd3 use hundreds of millions of
parameters
and most tools currently do not scale to
that
two it should not establish restrictions
dnns use many different types of
architectures many different types of
activation functions so ideally we would
want to
be generalizable so we wanted to work on
all if not all at least most dna
architectures
three we wanted to express any property
of dnn that can be tested
there's been a lot of research uh
finding new vulnerabilities of dnns
such as their vulnerability to
unfair behavior or their vulnerability
to bias
so it would help to have a tav method
that can
um that can express all of these
properties
as needed instead of having to design a
new tv method
for each of these properties separately
and four
it should be both sound and complete um
again
sound definitely and but complete
is a compromise that a lot of industry
experts are willing to
take just because current dna and tab
methods might not even scale
saying all that we can classify
the existing dnn tab methods
into the following categories one
testing methods and these methods are
search-based methods
and they're searching for inputs that
violate some property
they often use gradient information to
efficiently navigate that search space
but they could also use fuzzing or
genetic algorithms
in order to search or test these methods
are very scalable
uh they can work on industrial size
applications but they provide limited
expressibility
and they are sound but they're not
complete the next category we've got
this verification program analysis-based
methods
these methods encode the dnn model into
some symbolic form
usually a system of equations or some
smt encoding or set encoding and use a
corresponding solver
to either find inputs that violate this
property or
to prove that properties hold and they
are expressible but they're not scalable
at least the current ones and they
restrict the dna architectures
usually they restrict the type of
activation function used to
to just be relu or or just have one or
two
types of activation functions
reachability methods define an allowable
region
often uh defined geometrically as a
polytope
and they propagate that region
throughout the network
uh so this the propagated this output
region
encapsulates all the inputs possible
from that input region
and they use that method in order to
verify
they are somewhat more scalable than
verification program analysis based
methods
but they are limited in their
expressibility and they also restrict
the type of dna architectures used
and depending on the tool they can be
they are sound and depending on the tool
they can be
um complete
so as a consequence because there is no
one method
that is scalable um and
generalizable so that does not restrict
any architectures
while being expressible we
use what we're calling the constraint
gradient method
and at its core this leverages two
existing works the first one is this
approach
introduced by mark in the in their work
deep learning with differentiable logic
that converts these logical constraints
into differentiable loss
and so we've got
our own implementation of that and we've
encoded different kinds of constraints
in addition and two we're using a
modified gradient-based optimization
method
specifically the modification of the
fast gradient sine method
by goodfellow at all in order to find
inputs
that satisfy these constraints so the
first two slides i'm going to gloss over
very quickly because
um mark and vivek went over
uh the use of fluco shivats t norman
um why you know how that helps convert
these uh
constraints into these differentiable
laws
i just wanted to stress that because
this output of these constraints
is a differentiable loss we can apply
our gradient-based methods and in
practice
although i know mark mentioned this as
well
although this is differentiable almost
everywhere not everywhere
um it's worked well for us and uh we've
had to do a few tweaks in order to
make it work in our situation but
in practice it works pretty well for
testing um
and again a quick example the
standard reversal constraint from before
would be converted to this equation here
and it's in our case it's converted to
this
loss function that is suitable for a
deep learning platform
tensorflow and by touch now that we have
these cons
constraint loss as
mark mentioned we can use different
optimization algorithms to
find examples we've opted to use this
fastballing sign method because it's
efficient specifically
what we do is we calculate the gradient
of constraint loss
with respect to the input example and we
modify that input slightly
in the direction of decreased loss so
this is a very
cheap computational calculation
and it and it's been used
in um in many different types of
adversarial
attacks so because this is
um not complete we're not guaranteed to
produce
a solution but
we run this for multiple iterations and
we
we give it a fixed time and in practice
we find
properties we find examples that violate
these properties
many in in most cases
so in order to test the efficacy of this
method
we ran some experiments we used uh we
ran three sets of experiments each using
different
constraints um all these constraints
were
um using adversarial examples but um it
doesn't
but we can you can imagine that you can
test other types of
properties as well so the first uh
adversarial example
that we're looking at is the standard
one as given in the definition above
the second one that we're calling
natural adversarial examples
adds an additional constraint to the to
the previous one
and this constraint states that the
original label
should now be the second highest
classification and the intuition behind
this
is that the the neural network model
would
take this perturbed input and still have
a fairly high confidence
that it is on the original label
which is why it's still the second
highest
second highest classification however it
is still misclassified
and then the third example is a flow
adversarial example
and this uses work from xiaowital where
they're using spatial transformations
instead of
perturbing the pixels directly they're
moving the pixels around
so they introduce this flow loss and
which is what we've incorporated
just to showcase that many different
types of adversarial attacks can be
implemented using this idea one general
framework
for each of these experiments we
compared the cgd constrained gradient to
set method
against various tib tools on three
benchmarks
the first set of benchmarks uh use
models from vnn lib it's a
initiative international initiative by
a verification based team that are
trying to
provide these benchmarks for
verification tools
on dns the second set of benchmarks
we're calling robust models that
um that are trained adversarially so in
order to see how
this these models these attacks
can in order to see whether these
attacks work well
on these robustly trained models and the
third one is
resonant 18 which is a fairly large
model it has
around 11 million parameters in order to
see if these tools scale well
so for each of these tools we give it a
certain amount of time
and we record the time taken to produce
a counter example
or provide a certificate of
guarantee if it can provide that and we
are using part two scoring method
to calculate um essentially what we're
doing is if a method time runs out of
time
we're penalizing it by adding twice the
amount of time limit
so um here are some of our results
so on the y-axis here you see the part
two score
and each of these collections here
correspond to one of the tools that we
used
and each of the colors respond to each
of the experiments
so blue is the standard adversarial
example experiment
the red is the natural one and the
yellow is the flow
so from left to right we've got
constrained gradient descent here
carlini in wagner which is a
optimization based
testing method a bounded iterative
method fast gradient sign method
these three are testing optimization
based methods
then we have eran which is a
reachability tool
we have mip verify which is a
verification based uh
tool dl fuss is a testing method that
uses fuzzing
marabou is a verification method random
fuzz essentially
randomly fuzzes the inputs and genetic
algorithm which is a testing based
method
and for standard adversarial examples um
it's fairly clear to see that constraint
gradient descent
along with the other gradient-based
optimization methods
have a much better result so here the
lower the
the score the better because this
corresponds to amount of time taken
um and this makes sense because these
tools are
built for this um whereas the
reachability and verification tools
work fairly well on the smaller
benchmarks but
um on the larger benchmarks like resnet
they'll timeout and they're penalized
for it
uh in the case of natural adversarial
examples
um by default the gradient-based methods
don't allow for encoding that and so
they've timed out
in all of these whereas the reachability
and verification tools you can
encode that but it does take quite a
while and they do time out a lot on the
um on the resonant 18 models and the
flow adversarial example
um currently as it stands cannot really
be encoded
in the reachability and verification
tools
and they're not able to be used directly
in the other
gradient-based tools whereas in the
constraint gradient descent
by design they're able to be used and so
we see
some fairly great results here
so um i wanted to quickly conclude
so again current dnn tav methods can be
divided into
testing verification program analysis
and reachability methods
each method has its strengths and
limitations and
crucially there is no one method that
can scale well
to the dns used in industry while being
expressible for different properties
so we use this consumer gradient descent
method that leverages
the method of converting logical
constraints into loss
and use a modified gradient-based
algorithm in order to find examples that
minimize this loss
and we compare this against state of the
art tools on a collection of benchmarks
and show that it is just as scalable and
generalizable
um compared to state-of-the-art methods
further it can test for properties that
current methods
currently can't um and so it's easy it's
like a general framework where you can
test for many kinds of properties that's
needed
thank you venue thank you for a great
talk
for everybody uh there are questions
uh i think uh oh yeah
[Music]
so allow me to ask a question or two
here
you mentioned that the verification
methods uh
allow one to express
a very large class of properties right
right um
do you know how the the kind of
constraints that you are able to express
in your cgd method
how how the expressive power
is limited relative to say the
verification methods
um so in your case i guess
you have the the constraints have to be
in some sense differentiable
exactly so i think yeah yeah i think the
main the main thing is that the
constraints have to be differentiable
um now for example like the flow loss
um spatial perturbations by default are
not
differentiable but in the work of shower
tall what they did was to come up with a
differentiable
uh way like a relaxation where that is
differentiable
so as long as we can come up with these
relaxations
uh we may be able to express a lot more
properties
however that is still the main
limitation compared to
verification tools thomas did you have a
question
did you have a question thomas i thought
you raised your hand hello hello
um yes very interesting talk but i would
like to
i have a question for the second
last talk
to mark mark are you there
yes yes i'm here sorry oh good good um
well i um i really well the other talk
was also very good um
but i liked your your your try to to
to be as far as possible a little bit
more formal um you introduced to the
concept
of fairness and i was wondering whether
it is inspired by or maybe related to
somehow
to to the formalism by say
cynthia dework do you know that
uh no i think i'm not familiar with with
that
i'm sorry okay something ideas maybe
it's inspiring for you
um yeah it's it's definitely have a look
thank you okay
um so vanilla i had a couple of more
questions
one question was um
um where do you see this going like
uh constrained gradient the sun based
methods in terms of
the kind of properties that you can test
going forward
um yeah i think so what we're looking at
is
um is how to apply this for in other
settings like
for example natural language um
oftentimes
um the types of testing you can do in
natural language is
is not as it's quite limited
and there are no tools that can easily
test for
let's say all these different types of
settings same thing with
reinforcement learning models that use
neural network controllers so this can
be a very
general framework for testing
all these different kinds of models as
long as you give the right properties
you also tested uh adversely trained
models right and you were able to find
adversarial examples against them so
what does that say about
universal training as a defense
mechanism
so in those models in general those
models were
harder to attack for the gradient based
methods
however they were still able to attack
them and um
i think that's just because the current
adversarial um defense mechanisms
haven't caught up as much with the
adversarial attacks
i think that's just the um just an
artifact of that
thank you again for a great talk thank
you it's fantastic and thanks to all the
speakers today for
a fantastic talk set of talks and
this is going to be the last session of
the
sad smt foundations workshop we had a
phenomenal time organizing this um
starting in february and
all of the talks are available online
this was co-organized with
uh antonina kolokolova moshe vardy
uh marian holley maria bonay
am i missing somebody and kevin leighton
brown right
um and uh antonina do you want to add
some
few words and and maybe an announcement
or two
regarding your uh uh regarding the
session tomorrow
yeah um sure uh
first of all thank you so much everybody
for wonderful talks
and thank you all the attendees and
participants for
coming in for the semester really wish
the semester where in person but
life interfered um
so thank you so much for bearing with it
in this strange world in this strange
format
uh for the sad participants so
whoever else is interested just send me
an email
we are planning a town hall tomorrow
tentatively
at uh 11am and the fellows talk time
and it's the town hall
uh kind of where to go from there what
to do next
so if uh please come
we'll chat we'll see what to do and both
science logistics
and if you have some ideas again both
signs of logistics
please let me or um and or andrea no
um yeah everybody is welcome and i guess
right now there is a
tea time on gaza town right yeah
uh just to confirm you are going to send
out an
email to the participant confirming the
time and
the method so i'm still waiting to get
the zoom link i will send out the zone
link as soon as i
get it and i'm also hoping to confirm
that
it won't clash with anything if it's at
11 am but there should have been an
email
asking for ideas things to talk about
what people want to discuss that's kind
of our last
chance to get together as a program
before the reunion
and um share whatever we want to share
if you have a date for the reunion um
they don't have a date for the reunion
i've heard rumors that
if you really really ask we might be
able to get a longer union like a
month-long reunion
so hint if if you have a venue like a
survey where you could ask
that's one thing you could ask for and
hopefully
a year from now the reunion will be in
person it will be i guess sometimes next
summer
that's how it's usually done
okay so this is the last week for the
entire semester and thank you everybody
for
uh participating and contributing so
we'll see you soon in gather town and
tomorrow at the town hall
thank you yeah so gather town uh we
could go to work from gather town
or better yet to the um people who
program participants to the internal
gaza town
uh should i post a link yeah maybe you
should
yeah um okay i'll post the link to
the workshop as a tone but i think most
people will be on internal
all right thank you everybody bye-bye
thank you everybody